this is the backbone an accessory that
turns your phone into a mobile
PlayStation and I've been using it with
my friend Agent 47 for a few weeks now
the premise is simple attach your mobile
this is the Android version by the way
then download the Remote Play app to
Game On The Go making it a simplified
PSP the thing about Remote Play is that
wherever you are playing the backbone
your PS5 is still running back at home
so connection is everything I realized
that I tended to use this at home
whenever the main TV was stolen from my
grasps I mean who the heck watches
Vampire Diaries anyway remote gaming on
the couch was amazing with little to no
DeLay So the next test was to go into
the middle of nowhere and look at Art
and the results were quite hit and miss
sometimes the signal wasn't strong
enough to game at all and sometimes it
was absolutely superb playing a little
Spider-Man whilst touching grass was
pretty damn good